you are like every time you come in here
you look so Dapper so so you look great
too well someone a whole team of people
makes this happen I don't look like this
in general well same no I feel like you
probably look like this at Target okay I
appreciate I appreciate your optimism
when it comes to my how I look you
totally do probably but wait so New
Year's just Happ how do you celebrate
New Year's I have absolutely no
expectations for New Year I have no
lists no bar I have no I call them like
at the very because what is it New Year
resolutions yeah do
no obviously not I've tried every year
you try and every year you fail not to
be a fatalist but I'm just terrible at
them I don't like to say fail I like to
say just not there yet right right right
right working on it we're working it um
I don't love to work on things so I'm
just I love working on yes so you stick
to a list I will stick to the list and
it doesn't matter if it takes a decade
but I'm still doing it yeah I just like
to have I like goals I like yeah yeah
well well I also now like goalss and
want to set them for myself I do I I
don't know why I think it gives me
purpose like to go like okay this is the
thing I'm going I did a thing last year
where I said okay I was going to walk
every day and I was going to add like an
extra 5 minutes every time I walked okay
yeah and then 15 days
later I am on my couch yeah yeah yeah
there's no hiking there's no nothing and
the shoes are just sitting by my front
door like hiking you're from the most
beautiful place ever Canada is so
beautiful to hike it is very yeah yeah
didn't do
either just a hard no I love it so wait
you and your dad are both part of it's
called The Order of Canada right I
talked about this with your dad you're
now both a part of it yeah this is a big
deal in Canada I it is it's like I don't
it's like I don't know am I a KN now
like I don't know what that is I think
so I'm going to just be kned I guess is
what it comes down to you know it's like
a great honor I will say yes it's like a
tremendous honor and I don't want to
discredit Canada obviously but my dad
has been on here so many times that I
feel like that has been the great honor
and now it's my on top of like I should
be wearing my pin actually a I love your
dad he's he loves you so much I ditto I
love him so much that is the great honor
I mean you know a country recognizing
you is great um but being here is also
great I love has anybody is is there is
there ever in the Order of Canada is
there like a father son or a mother
daughter is there no idea I think that
you might be the first I'm just saying
it let's just say we're the first let's
just say it yeah breaking glass ceiling
I like it I like it I think you get
another one when that happens yes I
think you're just a special special
member you get another record sort of
right at the end just on the bottom page
well wait speaking of Dan's dad he told
a story about Dan the first time he was
at our show so let's see that yeah my
son was 15 and he was going to come with
us in Los Angeles we went down down for
the premiere yeah of the movie and the
night before the premiere he he said uh
he was on the phone call with his friend
back in Toronto and they said well
what's going on he said well I'm going
to the premiere of American Pie uh
tomorrow night with my folks and the
friend said oh don't see it with your
folks did you not did you not go
no no absolutely not absolutely not no I
called a friend they had just seen like
an advanced screening of it and said
whatever run in the opposite direction
of wherever your parents are in relation
to that film and I did and I never I
have yet to see it with them I did end
up seeing it for most of my high school
life people thought the movie was like a
biography of my life
yeah that is unfortunate which is really
unfortunate because I would have killed
to have had a life that interesting um
pie yeah I don't even know about the
ingredients of an apple pie but that's a
whole other
conversation um my I think my mother's
the opposite I would be fine I think in
that scenario I think my mother would
die okay I'm very open I'm very open I
will talk to my mother
about so will my sister and my mother
hates it wow like with a capital H okay
yeah I don't have that Dynamic oh my dad
is very sweet but no we there was no I
have no problem I could talk about any
anything with her like literally
anything and she and I try but she is
just not she is like why your mouth is
moving she's the opposite of what this
movie was to me yeah she's not into it
so I would have gone to the premiere
anyway your dad's a cool awesome movie I
would have you know it's like it's a
weird thing to grow up watching your dad
just hand out porn to some other
kid that was the his new movie good
graef if you can see it now on Netflix
so explain the movie for everybody Bud H
um it's like it's a it's kind of 180
from from my TV show that's what I was
going to say did you purposely kind of
do a departure from Comedy yeah I I mean
I'm I was never like a comic I wasn't a
standup I didn't I just happened to
write a funny show and play a sort of a
funny character great comedic timing so
I disagree with that statement I just I
yeah so I think there was a desire after
80 episodes of writing and Performing
comedy to do something very different so
uh this is a movie about grief and about
friendship and um my character loses his
husband and it's really an exploration
of that's the amazing Luke Evans um
which yeah it's like tough to Beautiful
cast
um it was a tough casting Choice um but
yeah it's B it's basically about how how
this group of friends uh react in the
aftermath of a very meaningful death and
um I just haven't seen a lot of movies
where friendship was the center of the
conversation yeah and that was the love
story it didn't require like romance but
that is a love like that's it's the
greatest love oh my gosh I I wouldn't
have survived several situations in my
life without my friend circle like do
you have that Circle yeah yeah of course
and I just felt like that deserved its
time in the spotlight I feel like so
many movies romcoms and certain dramas
it's all about the romance and the
friends kind of sit on the sidelines but
in life I feel like at least in my life
my friendship is so much at the center
of my life that it it just felt like a
nice film to kind of explore the meaning
of friendship yeah is it cuz it's
there's a lot of depth to this and a lot
of grief so like so is that hard for you
to do like on camera is that yeah I my
dog died days before I wrote the script
for this movie oh no yeah and he was
getting old and I knew that I was making
this movie and so for like the year
leading up to it I would like sometimes
catch him on my bed and be like don't
you dare it's too sad to like go through
it without you you and then he yeah he P
he passed away 5 days before I started
got the green light for the script and I
think there's times where things happen
in your life for a reason and I don't
know if I'd be able to write the script
for this movie with the same level of
like vulnerability or the same rawness
if it hadn't happened and so it's a I
feel very fortunate to have made
something that is a celebration of my
feelings for him I lost my grandmother a
year before that so it was a kind of a a
catharsis of feeling when it came to it
has nothing to do with them but it has
everything to do with the feeling yeah
so it's a hard feeling like cuz I think
we compartmentalize a lot you know you
compartmentalize what's going on and
then all of a sudden it'll randomly hit
you yeah and grief is this weird thing
where I feel like everyone is going
through grief of some kind and I think
while you're going through it you can
feel very isolated by it whether you're
doing it right whether you whether
there's an appropriate way to grieve
something or length of time or length of
time again and so this movie is really
kind of explores the idea of that and
what it mean what grief really means and
is there a way to do it properly so it
was my way of kind of working through a
thousand questions that I had going on
in my head and that's the best art
though when someone's actually in that
raw moment and that what comes out of
that is you can it's um it's transparent
when you're the viewer um so oh I heard
this about your grandma actually she
loved your first story your very first
story that you wrote was that yeah there
was a I wrote a story about a young
princess that um travel to Russia um it
was a very epic story that was not good
and yet I remember her sort of pulling
me aside saying that she was very moved
by it she was very touched by it and
that I think is true love when you can
read something terrible and really I
think genuinely convince your grandchild
that you think they're great so yeah it
was one of the early votes of confidence
in my in my writing oh my God that's
what I say in my world like it's like if
you see someone sing and it's just like
so offkey but looking at their
significant other looking at them and
like that's love yeah because they don't
hear it no they hear wonderful like and
it's kind of the same with like people's
kids too like sometimes you look at a
kid and you're
like I thought you were G to whoa
um and the and the parent the parent is
like behind the the stroller being like
oh this is love and then you and then
you go that is love that is they see
through it it's also why I'm not having
kids clearly
so love them but okay so you this movie
was set in Paris did you do that on
purpose just so you could hang out in
Paris kind of a little bit I mean it's
set in London and Paris um for a variety
of reasons obviously but also because
you were like let's do that um no it was
a it's a it's a lovely story about like
some you know I play kind of a guy that
moved there to to kind of rebuild my
life and um it's oh that's our lovely
cast and jam and Ruth and himesh and we
just had the greatest time and yeah we
we traveled to London and Paris
Paris the food at lunch on a movie in
Paris oh no all I care about most of the
time is food I know that's what I'm
saying I would gain so much weight it
was you'd break for lunch and there
would just be tables as far as the I can
see of like Breads and pastries and
meats and veg and kiche and things that
I actually believed that we were more
productive in Paris just so people could
break for
lunch they were like must get done yeah
yeah we got to get let's wrap this up
cuz we have to get to the lunch table
they can do a a Shak cutre board I love
all that I could survive all of it yeah
of course and then apparently they used
to also serve wine at lunch why not well
and then Apparent from what the french
said the American Productions came and
really took advantage of the wine at
lunch so they had to scrap the wine at
lunch or but Americans weren't used to
it so just I think they were indulging
second half of the day yeah it was um it
wasn't as elegant as the French I think
at the end of the day so okay I think
that since it's based in Paris um I
thought we could play a game about
movies like in Paris
yeah well you can see Dan's movie good
grief now on Netflix and you can see me
whoop his behind neck stay right
[Music]
here
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home